a ton of questions for you this morning
uh earlier this year in January I tried
asking you a question and you deflected
I'm going to start this interview off
seeing what I can get uh are you still
involved in the Assassin's Creed thing I
am no longer involved in the Assassin's
Creed thing
so would it be a difference of your
version of what they wanted to do or I I
think it was uh it was a little bit of
of a move of Executives from LA to
London and and it allowed the London
group who had unfortunately you know
they had to inherit my vision of what it
was and instead of getting to develop
their own Vision so I think that's fair
I think that you know
um I I know it's going to be great
whenever it comes out I think the
Ubisoft guys are fantastic I think it's
a terrific you know franchise it was
just a good Mutual you know time to move
on for for both sides Hey look it's not
like you're not busy you know it's uh I
know you know um so you've made now
three seasons of Vikings
um which season ended up being the most
challenging because I'm curious if it's
season one when you're building the
infrastructure or further along when you
know what you can do and you're trying
to push even further without a doubt
that's a great question uh without a
doubt season one was hard for exactly
the reason you said you know I felt like
I was out there in the wilderness saying
we can do this you know we can take down
London bridge you know in on TV uh and
make it look like we just you know did a
40 million dollar you know action set
piece uh I I I I I we can do this we can
break off from you know the the Michael
Hurst tree and stand alone as its own
type of show we can tell a show with a
lot more action and suspense and and
many more characters and all of those
type of things that's hard when you're
out there alone sometimes just saying
you know it's going to work it's going
to work it's going to be fun it's going
to be great you know trust me you know I
hate the word
trust me you know that's just that we
got that behind us season two becomes a
challenge because okay you did it in
season one what are you going to do for
season two that it's almost like doing a
sequel It's almost like you know it's
it's it's got to be faithful to
everything you did for season one and
yet it's got to be new and fresh and
even better for season two so you have
to take risk when you do sequels and and
if you want them to be successful I
think we took some great risks in season
two so that made it harder
um you know telling everybody trust me
we can we can break up the band and it's
still it still will work uh season three
is uh uh it was hard just simply because
it's you know you're bringing everything
back around again and you're chopping
season two and season one so anyway I
can't answer that story other than or
that question other than say they're all
hard Steve I mean it's all tough
uh so you filmed the first two seasons
borderline back to back
um I'm not sure if how much of a break
there was but with season three you shot
that on your own and I am curious
because the first season was such a hit
was there any talk with Netflix about
hey do you want to do three and four
together or like we can only really get
ready for season three if you want you
know what I mean like did you ever
discuss that possibility we really
talked about one two and three as sort
of a block
um and then
uh hopefully we could get to a four five
and six because the the the story is you
know I think you'll see when you see
season two and season three it's it's
almost like a novel it's it has these
wonderful time you know time jumps and
and and and and growth in terms of
particular characters and you know like
a really big great novel it's got it
it's got a a several understories you
know that just that are holding things
up that you don't really feel they're
like light motifs that you don't really
see but you suddenly feel them there so
I'm hoping we have the opportunity to
complete that Journey
um but I feel that
um I think one two and three
um
you know are are are all standalones all
all good like that
you know I'm I'm happy I'm a happy guy I
you know I'm getting to tell a really
cool story with lots of great action and
great characters and a cast that I love
working with and crew
what's there to you know complain about
oh no totally so so you're saying that
you think if the show gets to continue
the goal would be to try to shoot four
five and six actually together if we got
a chance to do this and and you know
from you know your mouth to God's ear
okay if we got a chance to shoot this
yes it it's a continuation because the
first part was thought of as a sort of a
triptych this the second part should be
thought of as well now if I only got you
know one season to go I'll take it one
at a time and do whatever I have to do
but the um uh these things are always
better when you get to play on a large
canvas you know it's it it it's better
does it actually impact the budgeting if
you are actually going to shoot
hypothetically if you were to shoot four
five and six together does that impact
the budget where you save money because
you're doing it all together versus
doing you know season four one at a time
there's no question that you can
amortize especially for a big action
show like like ours if if you can
amortize across you know a season or
across you know a season and a half uh
which we we can and can't do you know if
Allah we you know each each season is
its own company and that sort of thing
but we we think of it uh we have we can
use category I can I know we'll be in
Connecticut at in season three as well
as season two as well as season one so
it's not like I'm I'm each year I'm
having to build a separate piece and yet
I can build separate pieces to pop in
thinking that I've got a couple more
seasons out there uh I can think about
costumes I can think about Weaponry I
mean you you know our Armory is gigantic
our our you know our Fleet is gigantic
you know so what boats will I need for
season five I can start thinking about
it in season four there's a lot of uh a
lot of that that would obviously help
just from a financial situation so I
spoke to you earlier this year in
January for season one and I'm talking
to you now with season two coming out in
January you have filmed season three is
the plan for January 2024 for season
three like is the plan for every January
to release one we we don't have any
commitment at this point we hope we we
do but we we don't at this point we're
we're still just starting to do the
post-production on season three so we've
got a long throw as far as that's
concerned uh I'm hoping that we you know
I would love to get a pickup we'd love
to be you know continue this journey if
that if we're lucky enough to have that
happen we'll be ready whenever we're
ready sure uh I gotta stop already I'm
just gonna say congrats I would be
really surprised if you're not making
more seasons and good luck with the rest
of your speed dating today
thanks Steve